welcome to this video playing and
Simmons unsat su and set so something on
the US and is the country at least the
flag here let's see greenfeld Kings
Indian the Kings Indian care play the
armor buck again lots of Kings Indians
really it's still a very popular opening
on amateur level yeah the Kings Indian
always attracts people and because of
the active possibilities in this in the
classical bishop age 694 was the idea
White's plan years to regroup the bishop
to see to and 92 ok wants to play a fire
really badly um 92 first opieop see to
look not not clear um yeah I guess I
just take and 92
yeah this is somewhat comparable to them
to Z mesh variation where why does oh
this is surprising is some giving up
efore yeah interesting okay i will take
that's an interesting decision but can
even take on h 7 and then stall nights
on e4 and c3 this is some strategically
very nice yeah I do the check it's
possible that this is a mistake but i
like that a gem 22 oh yeah this I don't
mind I can I can just put the King here
I like the idea to only have the Knights
en this position controlling the center
totally and when in this configuration
that would be a bishop on c 2 i'm not
quite sure that the sea to bishop is
helping me in any way it's maybe just a
Supes superfluous piece
okay let's let's see how to play that I
will I will block the queenside on the
queenside completely okay shouldn't
forget to protect this and then the King
over to be three and now let's see how
to continue here of course it's about g4
mg4 at the right moment could be could
be the could could do the trick here
this also mmm that's old ideas with d6
yeah I don't I don't know come on let's
let's do this now takes rook takes
I can take now and play Knight g3 check
it's a bit of a problem for him you
fiber singing check with the check black
resigns yeah I don't know it was it was
interesting an interesting positional
idea f4 is some I mean taking one h7 f4
is really questionable with them with
them giving up the foursquare I cannot
really believe it that is good the only
question is what about this Bishop ages
7 move I like the idea but certainly
debatable I was I wasn't sure if you if
we think about a position where let's
say I put nights here and here I wasn't
sure if my bishop is doing so much it's
sort of competing for the same squares
that my nights are so I chat ok why not
why not grab this and don't check hey
this is I think no problem the the King
I want to go to the queenside anywhere
anyway maybe you should play a for
preventing this this is Pawn a formal
letter that I did later I mean here-here
think white is very comfortable I have a
total block he cannot open up the
position for the bishop bishops and a
long-term can really get in this this G
form and the way it went I played it
directly like here oh maybe up ok the
country that wants to take with the pawn
which is not bad intending g-form
playing it very strategically not a bad
idea yeah this is this was of course
blundering blonde
during the game away I thought this year
would also be quite nice for me let's
say rook g8 and then go from there I
wasn't sure what exactly to do now the
computer suggests nite nite f-22 d3 just
regrouping to maybe a gained upon that's
interesting
interesting now threaten each is 725
with a check and this is this is a good
move next this is what the engine wants
to play but this is just good for wide
and I note that there's also this year
but this way both nights are doing
something well on when there were an f2
and like here here the knight on c3 is
not doing anything and with this
regrouping it says it's activated yeah
this was just a blundering blundering
away this this material okay thanks for
watching